en 40 años benito tendrá un servicio la
edad que tiene actualmente qué edad
tiene bendito ahorita y bueno este es un
problema de edad así que vamos a
resolverlo con calma lo primero que hay
que hacer es pues ver qué es lo que
queremos y lo que queremos es la edad
que tiene benito justo ahora justo ahora
y entonces lo que nos conviene es
definir una variable como la edad que
tiene justo ahora entonces sea x igual a
la edad que tiene
benito actualmente en este preciso
momento que es la edad edad que tiene
benito justo ahora
la edad que tiene bendito actualmente y
qué va a pasar en 40 años bueno nosotros
nos queremos fijar y todo está
establecido en 40 años así que déjame
ponerlo aquí en 40 años que va a pasar
bueno pues benito va a tener 40 años más
de la edad que tiene ahorita es decir x
más 40 va a tener la edad que tim
hábitat que son x años más 40 años es
decir benito va a tener x más 40 años
muy bien pero no solamente nos dice eso
el problema lo que nos dice es otro dato
muy importante en 40 años
benito va a tener un cpc su edad la edad
que tiene justo ahora la edad que tiene
actualmente es decir en 40 años
benito va a tener 11 veces su edad x más
40 tiene que ser igual a 11 veces la
edad que tiene ahorita es decir 11 por
equis y entonces aquí ya nos surge la
idea de tener una ecuación x más 40 lo
que va a pasar en 40 años va a ser igual
a 11 veces su edad la edad que tenga 40
años
once veces rueda actual es decir 11 x x
11 veces su edad actual esto tiene que
ser igual a la edad que va a tener
benito en 40 años es decir x más 40 y
entonces cuántos esto o cómo resolvemos
esta ecuación bueno lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que ya le
hicimos porque tenemos una ecuación con
una sola incógnita y de hecho lo que
vamos a hacer es resolver esta ecuación
que no se ve tan difícil de hacer lo
primero que voy a hacer es restar x de
ambos lados de la ecuación para que me
quede todo el lado izquierdo que dependa
solamente de la variable x entonces
menos x por aquí menos x por acá y que
me va a quedar 11 x menos x
bueno esto es 10 veces x entonces déjame
ponerlo 10 veces x mientras que del otro
lado del lado derecho que me queda
x menos x se van se eliminan se cancelan
son 0 y solamente me queda el 40
x es igual a 40 perfecto pero yo lo que
quiero no es el valor de 10x sino de x y
por lo tanto voy a dividir entre 10
ambos lados de la ecuación 1010 se van
de tal manera que solamente me queda uno
déjenme escribirlo aquí abajo entonces x
es igual a 40 entre 10 40 entre 10 es 4
entonces perfecto ya tengo que x vale 4
y x es justo lo que yo quería la edad
que tiene benito actualmente ya puedo
contestar que benito tiene actualmente
cuatro años cuatro años solamente tiene
benito y en 40 años pues en 40 años
benito va a tener x más 40 es decir 44
años y sería muy bueno corroborar que
realmente cumpla lo que dice nuestro
problema es decir que 44 o sea 11 veces
4 pero eso es cierto 4 por 11 es 44 por
lo tanto hemos llegado al resultado